hey guys this is just a very small
simple tutorial video on how to change
ground textures in roller coaster can
three using tax mode and the packages
that old spice is made for it this will
just be a very simple follow me tutorial
that's been requested a number of times
and I figured it would also help to kind
of shed light on the fact that this is
actually possible and yeah the basic
introduction of what text mode is
exactly and what this does with your
game is text mother's a program using
which you can open and modify tech
students from games and then create text
create packages of that and using the
program itself open those packages and
open the game but you don't actually
modify the game itself you just launch
the game using text mod and you only get
these custom textures and other things
if you launch this game using text mode
so there's no real harm to it as far as
I know when it comes to your game itself
though all spies did say that he's not
responsible for any problems that this
might cause but it has been proven to be
pretty safe now the first thing you're
going to want to do is you're going to
want to download text mode that makes a
lot of sense you don't have to install
anything you can just go to this website
it's safe it'll automatically download
you've got to read me which says some
stuff we don't really need that too much
just for the sake of this video I'm
going to put it on my desktop so I know
and that is make sure that you still
know where it is just so you're able to
open it later on because you're going to
want to open this thing every single
time that you're going to want to open
the game with these different textures
so make sure that it's an easy to find
and location that you know where to find
actually and second thing you're going
to want to do is you're going to want to
download all spices packages that he's
made for this these these are basically
the things that you need to load into
text mode before you can open roller
coasters in three with these new
textures and it will take a while and
let me skip that so when you've
downloaded these you're going to want to
expect these to any location on your pc
i'm just going to extract it to my
desktop because that's easy for the sake
of this tutorial you don't have to open
these every single time that you want to
open the game but i'll show that right
now once you open text mode you can see
this thing that looks pretty complicated
you don't have to worry about logging
mode or package build you don't need
that as long as you are not modifying
the game yourself since Old Spice has
already done that
everybody who wants to do this so what
you're going to want to do is you're
going to want to go into your roller
coaster and three directory while you
also where you also install your custom
scenery and all that stuff so your local
disk program files that's already boloco
second three and then you're going to
want to open the ICT three plus make
sure you don't open the Installer by the
way and the second thing that you do is
um you're going to want to open these
files that Old Spice has made so the
modeling files themselves so for this
case I'm going to want to go to my
desktop where I've saved them and open
those both and you'll notice that when I
open that thing there were already some
things in that you could already see the
extras and the ground in here which is
because I'm installed those earlier on
which means that as soon as you've
loaded this you only have to do this
once you only have to browse for them
once and after that for the rest of the
Eternity of having text mode they will
stay there how even I try to get rid of
text mob just for this tutorial to make
sure that I didn't have those things yet
but they were still saved over there but
this is actually all you have to do now
you can click on run and it'll
automatically play boloco second three
this is not the usual launch so you're
not using the actual game itself you're
not modifying the actual game itself but
this does mean that every single time
that you're going to want to use these
custom textures and extras you're going
to want to use this launcher rather than
using roller coaster can three itself
alright so once that slowpoke is finally
loaded you'll notice that once you open
the terraforming you've got a load of
new textures that you can use the old
ones have disappeared you cannot use the
in-game textures and the new text is at
the same time but overall I just find
these texts to be a lot better it really
just depends on which ones you like more
which ones you're going to want to use
but one thing that these sectors do have
is the resolution is twice as high as
the in-game textures but other than that
they work pretty much the same way you
can just scatter them around as you're
used to with the in-game textures that
are some texts that don't blend and some
texts that blend very well and just a
variation of different grants textures
snow textures and rock text is kind of
like you have the knee in game version
as well as that's pretty much what's
news a couple of other points which
people don't really see as much but
they're very subtle changes that I CLE
do
like a lot for example the color of the
sky is also changed actually in this
what you what you will notice in the
in-game without changing the textures
with this program is that the sky is
going to turn red as soon as it's 1pm
but in this version that weird sky you
is not going to happen until it's
actually evening which is something that
I really like about this I will see that
it only starts turning red after about 3
p.m. and even then it's going to be a
very slow and subtle change into the
night sky the night sky by the way is
something that I should probably also
noted probably also say is very
different it actually has a different
style text you so you don't have the
weird Milky Way band anymore which you
have if you're using the in-game
textures and you may also notice but
this is just a very very subtle change
is that the clouds have a slightly
higher resolution one other thing is
also that if you play some lights let me
just get the voting's lights for example
over here let's see there we go and
let's place one of these down one thing
that you'll see is that you'll get a bit
of a star you effect which actually
don't have with the in-game light
effects and so that's a very subtle and
nice change as well I think that's
pretty much everything that was really
noteworthy about this i really recommend
getting it even if it's just for the
ground textures it's some really good
stuff and it just helps a lot trying to
make more realistic stuff so yeah that's
it for this video thank you guys for
watching if you have any questions feel
free to ask them one thing that I should
probably note at the end is that this
does not work the same way for the steam
version to be exactly sure how to do it
if you have any problems you might want
to check out the thread which I did link
in the description because there are
also some feedback comments on how you
how you should get it to work on Steam
the way that you generally do it is you
change the text mode but EXE to onct 3
plus dot exe so once you launch the game
on steam it actually opens text mode
rather than boloco second three and you
also change the game of the roller
coaster can 3 plus executable to
something else doesn't really matter
what and then you open that using text
mode but it sounds pretty complicated
when I say it so check out the thread if
you
got any problems with that or any
problems with this thing otherwise but
you can also leave some comments so yeah
so you got